à villepreux commune de près de onze
mille habitants il y aura au moins cinq
candidats pour ces élections municipales
dont le premier tour est je le rappelle
le 15 mars prochain parmi eux coureurs
golgoht lab
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous avez 50 3 ans
vous êtes médecin de profession et vous
conduirez la liste tout simplement
villepreux au scrutin je précise que
vous êtes le président du mouvement
citoyen notre ville près de la
copropriété à des eaux du moulin
pourquoi vous engagez cette fois ci dans
une démarche politique
écoutez je suis comme vous avez dit le
président d'une copropriété à villepreux
donc je rencontrais des difficultés sur
ma copropriété qu'ils s'agissent que
l'entretien des espaces verts des
installations publiques donc à chaque
fois les gens me considérait comme un
référent comme un maire local il se
retourner vers moi et alors qu en fait
en tant que président la copropriété je
n'ai pas beaucoup de pouvoir
au niveau local donc j'ai été confronté
à l'institution publique à la mairie à
saint quentin pour les faire intervenir
et ma démarche était que j'ai dû
colliger les différents un problème de
ma copropriété et j'ai dit au moment des
élections politiques municipales je vais
aller voir les différents candidats et
soumettre les problèmes qui se posent la
circulation la densification de
l'urbanisation des problèmes des espaces
faire la sécurité et à mes questions se
sont rajoutés les questions de toute la
ville progressivement est jeune et qu'on
s'a portées par les candidats n'a pas
été satisfaisant quand je me suis
retrouvé face à des candidats qui
étaient particulièrement
il me rejeter arrogant j'ai été insulté
j'étais menacé de procédure alors que
j'étais pas candidat aux élections et
ils m'ont invité à faire une liste
et c'était assez dur pour moi qui est
qui et 30 ans ou 35 ans de carrière
professionnelle derrière moi j'avais
j'ai été traité comme ça et vous avez un
temps envisagé de vous allier au maire
sortant stephen mirambeau avant d'y
renoncer
les jutra été assez critique sur
l'exacte internet à votre égard il peut
moi je pense qu'il est un petit peu amer
après notre séparation les questions que
je suis mis là que j'ai soumise la seule
personne qui a accepté de répondre
malgré la dureté des questions que je
lui ai posé sur sur son mandat sur son
comportement c'était la seule personne
qui a accepté de me répondent sans
arrogance sans menaces et sans insultes
il pourrait s'agit s'est pas fait au
final cette union alors l'union dont qui
m'a invité grédy rejoint - tu me rejoins
et on va faire j'ai dit pourquoi pas
donc il fallait une cohérence dans ma
démarche et on n'a pas pu se mettre
d'accord parce que tout ce que je
voulais proposer sur la culture sur
l'urbanisme
finalement il n'était pas trop d'accord
il était un petit peu dans un esprit de
revanche qui étaient toutes à totalement
compréhensible du fait qu' il ya une
implosion de sa majorité dans deux
listes différentes qui s'entendent
d'ailleurs pas ensemble et un contexte
tendu aussi on rappelle qu'une plainte
est toujours en cours d'instruction pour
harcèlement sexuel alors pour moi c'est
à lui et aux grands de tous âges et même
pas facebook je peux cinq premiers
patients ou les personnes que je crois à
jour avec qui je dois travailler
justin dans un premier temps qu'ils sont
bons us et ils doivent faire preuve de
leur de leur qualité
donc je voulais pas entrer là dedans on
a été salie quand on salit quelqu'un on
salue aussi sa ville et les gens les
plaignants ils se retrouvent sur les
deux listes
municipales sont aujourd'hui mais mais
mais mais mais mais mais mais rivaux
donc je voulais pas entrer dans ces
considérations j'ai dit ça il faudra que
tu vois de ton côté
si jamais il y à une procédure est mise
en examen il faudra qu aux lentilles à
la conséquence donc on a préféré et
retrouver chacun sa liberté et à ce
moment là il a été un maire et donc vous
avez ville et les reproches ou les
insultes qui ont été moins lourde envers
moi sur un terreau discus ça veut dire
si vous avez envisagé de vous allier
stéphanie en beau que d'une certaine
manière vous êtes satisfait de ce qu'il
a pu mener les projets qu'il a pu mener
à la tête de la ville depuis 2008 jean
quel regard vous portez là aujourd'hui
je me sens et de son jour le problème
c'est que je travaillais 12 jours avec
lui les autres listes ont frappé 12 ans
avec lui et je m'explique toujours sur
ce projet d'alliance le j'abandonnais
mon projet passe derrière le bilan de
stéphane rambaud sur le plan financier
était positif je vous rappelle que il a
été il est est rééligible à 60% d'élus
et avec ses affaires la majorité a
exposé jeu donc
par contre il a laissé tomber beaucoup
de choses dans la vie lisse est axé
principalement sur l'urbanisme avec une
densification à je dirais à outrance la
culture il a complètement abandonné la
sécurité en manque de policiers on a du
mal à recruter l'éducation notre collège
n'aura pas assez de place et il a ils
ont tout le monde même les listes qui
sont jour deux concurrentes
ils ont accepté ils ont voté le 17
décembre la vente d'une partie du
terrain du collège pour construire
encore des immeubles ce que je ne valais
pas mais un projet notamment celui du
central park c'était le quartier on le
met en suspens depuis longtemps mais qui
a l'air si j'ai l'honneur d'être élue
équipe qu'on me fait confiance on la met
en suspens et on va revisiter le
programme pour voir notre mille mètres
carrés même vivement
alors il ya même une question d'une
nappe phréatique en dessous qu'on a
essayé de passer sous silence on sait
pas si c'est cette nappe phréatique est
valable existantes ou pas et franchement
la ville est content on ne peut pas
absorber on va on va passer de 10000
habitants à quatorze mille habitants aux
alentours de 2025 nous c'est un projet
que vous le souhaitez mettre de côté
juste pour préciser les choses vous êtes
adhérent les républicains est ce que
cette liste la liste que vous portez va
porter cette couleur justement où il y
aura diverses sensibilités partie des
républicains qui vont apprendre que je
suis candidat ils sont même pas au
courant je pense que l'histoire le
problème de la ville
qu'il s'agisse des espaces faire des
poubelles la sécurité c'est pas une
histoire d'hommes était républicain et
notre ville jeudi à l'investiture vous
nous revendiquer pas d'investiture en
jeu non il ya une candidature soit dire
qu'il l'est républicain il est
génération des terrains je crois on
change de label deux mois après moi
personnellement j'ai aucun soutien
politique sur le parking au pied des
pentes qui est un adhérent mais sur ma
liste et des gens de tous bords
politiques
moi je suis pas un politicien je suis un
habitant de villepreux de plus 20 ans je
veux améliorer ma ville réanimer la
culture redonner une santé de proximité
un centre de santé de garde
mais il ya le genre de vol est de
proposer une nouvelle offre de santé sas
a fait écho aussi à votre profession de
médecin c'est quelque chose d'important
c'est très important parce
qu'aujourd'hui de quelqu'un qui à
villepreux ou aux clayes-sous-bois quand
il a un accident quand il a une urgence
il faut qu'ils se déplacent à poissy
bouche et nez avec les urgences saturé
on peut on a les possibilités mais il
faut avoir les réseaux il faut avoir la
connaissance il faut avoir l'âge pour
aller discuter avec le médecin et les
toubibs rôle ou prennent en
considération de développer un centre de
garde qui serait qui sera ouvert de 8
heures du matin à minuit avec un minimum
par exemple une radiologie eau chaude et
pulmonaires et qu'on fasse le tri et le
traitement des gens sur place
c'est un service aux personnes âgées et
aux personnes en situation de handicap
aux enfants c'est primordial
donc d'autres projets vous les avez
évoqué juste pour terminer villepreux
est une commune bien sûr intégré dans
cette agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines depuis 2016 avec forcément des
projets à mener au niveau intercommunal
la commune qui est bien représenté
stephen mirambeau et vice président de
l'agglomération sylvie ce vin montel à
une délégation à l'école innovantes quel
regard vous portez sur le travail mené
au sein de l'agglomération ce qu'il est
suffisant est-ce qu'il faut l'améliorer
et l'horizon ils ont globalement nous
ont pas fait du mauvais travail je
conçois la précédente municipalité a
bien travaillé ce que je regrette c'est
que lille pour eux ils ont laissé partir
les commerces
on n'a pas soutenu contrairement par
exemple aux clés on a une petite
subvention de l'agglomération 700000
euros contre 7 millions de presque 7
millions d'euros pour les caisses du
bois avec à peu près la même population
on a très peu de marge de manoeuvre
alors ça aussi c'est un élément que la
municipalité n'a pas su défendre pendant
huit derrière du commerce de proximité à
ce que l'or leurs taxes leur
contribution compter pour cette
subvention qu'on ne touche plus
aujourd'hui si on n'a pas de marge de
manoeuvre
ils ont fait des éléments positifs mais
ils ont oublié beaucoup de choses et je
répète la culture un théâtre et qui
coûte entre 40 à 70 milles euros
aussi subventionné par l'agglomération
mais qui est fermé portes fermées pour
les rendez vous de campagne pour
terminer alors nous avons quatre dates
le 25 janvier le l'étape au moins début
février
et puis fin février et début mars
alors les dates exactes je peux vous les
donner et 25 janvier
samedi 25 janvier samedi 20 février
samedi 22 février et dimanche 1er mars
merci coureuses gaulle gollop tête de
liste de tout simplement villepreux à ce
scrutin des municipales face à vous la
candidature est du maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau celle de l'ex
adjointe sylvie se vend montel valérie
ben porter une candidature citoyenne
enfin là le délégué départemental du
modem jean baptiste à monique sera
également tête de liste